jeez oh hey
look at you
happy tuesday what a marvelous time to
be alive
well if you aren't working for cnn plus
sick burn
but you should consider yourself lucky
and grateful and not just because you're
watching a former calvin klein underwear
model who also happens to be the king of
late night
although you should be
gratitude matters i even thanked my
assistant today by not making her cry
when the soup she brought me had only
three sliced shallots instead of four
i still threw it in her face
so do you know do you show enough
gratitude for all the great things in
your life are you grateful for your
family your friends your proctologist
with really slender fingers that matters
and what about me are you thankful for
me
then why didn't you show it why not get
a tattoo of my name on your face
what's stopping you your upcoming job
interview your loved ones dignity
well that's not stopping louis angel
hernandez this la gang member convicted
of murder vows to get the ultra woke
district attorney george gascon's name
tattooed on his face
for saving years off his sentence
now he might be lying after all he is a
murderer
but it's great
now we can identify failed liberal
policies by the tattoo on our
assailant's faces hernandez had pleaded
guilty to murder as well as personal use
of a firearm for the killing of a pot
delivery person back in 2018. it raises
the question what other kinds of uses
are there besides personal use when
you're the shooter last time i checked
smith and wesson didn't have a friends
and family plan
but also he killed a pot delivery person
why not just kill santa claus am i right
cat
cause i do drugs
the audio of a jailhouse phone call
obtained by fox news has the murderer
gushing about the great things gascone
did for him
now we got a new da in la so they're
gonna on for i got caught on the 14th
fool right there in compton thursday so
they're gonna drop a gang of um
like my gun enhancement and my gang and
ass man my gang has been 10 years full
for being a gang member
is making historic changes for all of us
not just murderers we pass laws and then
he ignores them just like the criminals
and with people like hernandez back on
the streets we become history too
and if he kills us all he has to do is
get another tattoo
your last words could be why would you
ruin your face
but of course nothing says tough on
crime like getting a ringing endorsement
from a convicted murderer
at least someone is finally thanking
democrats
but then again maybe perps getting
tattoos to celebrate skating free
is more common than we think
man this story about that tattoo guy's
insane huh no who hasn't gotten a tattoo
to celebrate beating the system wait a
minute you've done that yeah this is
when i beat that shoplifting charge wow
cat that is absolutely insane you look
like you're in a biker game this one on
my stomach this is when i didn't get in
trouble for loitering oh my god the
colors are so vivid it really
accentuates your mid-drift oh my
favorite one's probably this one on my
bicep i didn't even get in trouble for
taking a tag off a mattress oh my god
you're so muscular and hairy
that is an all-timer
so
so hairy
initially uh this gang banger faced a
life sentence without the possibility of
parole facing what's called several
enhancements and i'm not talking about
collagen injections or breast implants
for example being in a gang should add
10 years to your sentence but that means
of course more jail time and in the
modern woke handbook
that's the very worst containing
criminals is seen as oppressive
especially to them it infringes on their
rights to go out and mug rape or murder
and do you really have the right to deny
them that right they're oppressed enough
as it is but in a world with pregnant
men the perpetrators are the victims
after all we're just subjects in the
left's great cultural experiment what
happens to us when we let violent thugs
out into the general population and
eliminate
disincentives for crime you don't have
to be matlock or angela lansbury or any
other tv detective that i have a poster
of next to my bed which is shaped like a
race car
fyi
of course after those enhancements were
dropped thanks to gascone back in 2020
crime and murder shot up quicker than
nikki's six three minutes before
showtime
so hence the show of appreciation by
getting a new tattoo now every time
someone asks about the tattoo he has to
tell them it's because i'm a murderer
well good luck getting a job
but you got to hand it to gascoigne he's
got some serious street cred i mean gang
bangers love this lawyer they're victims
not so much but i don't know if there's
anything i love that much to get its
name tattooed on my face let me think
yeah
i wonder what cad would have
ugh
jerk
although d to harry jerk although
details of hernandez's new sentence
aren't clear according to fox news he'll
be able to qualify for youth offender
parole or yap
which limits his sentence to 25 years
and if you think he'll serve that out
you're as nutty as a king-sized payday
bar he'll finish his sentence around the
time i finish this one
[Music]
he's on our list of 40 under 40 who look
like they're 14. host of the guy benson
show and fox news contributor guy benson
she puts the fun in discussing hybrid
money market funds
fox business correspondent susan lee
he's called box office poison because
the audience takes cyanide
writer and comedian joe devito
[Applause]
and finally she proves blondes have more
fun if by fun you mean arrest warrants
fox news contributor cat tim
you know before we start i just want to
point out that half our studio audience
is stuck in an elevator that's how small
our audience is
i'm not kidding gene is stuck in an
elevator been there for like a long time
you know what i don't care
i don't care you know he is that's where
he is he did not know that really yeah
he's stuck in an elevator been there for
a long time
so anyway guys back to the show
back to the show uh what is the point of
being awoke d.a like why would you why
is it does letting criminals back onto
the street help them like what is the
point
first of all i want to make sure that i
get my royalty check for that shot of
the tattoo on my abdomen
are you that hairy um
that's like a bear i mean
the kind of bear you like
greg knows the answer to his own
question actually uh but look i think
you're going at this whole story all
wrong you're of course coming at it from
a very negative perspective very fox
news of you yes this is an inspirational
story of redemption there's a beautiful
friendship that's blossoming here and
you just want to focus on the murder yes
i mean sometimes murderers get tattoos
representing their victims
this guy is getting one representing the
guy who's helping him out like his d.a
buddy and i think this could be like
maybe a sitcom or something in this
so you're saying yes this is like
progress it's like progress we've gone
from we've actually and it is a little
it it's kind of
uh
impressive that he knows enough about
gascone no he's like a wonk on the
details of criminal justice exactly
what else are you going to do in prison
yes he's going to be out soon a cat so
you better say something nice about him
he's cute
[Laughter]
jean is so gene is a big boy he can
handle himself let's talk about what are
the impacts of face tattoos in job
interviews you're on the fbn yeah what
do people get it's got to reduce your
chances for a job yeah well yes i didn't
even think about it that way because i
thought it was the stupidest thing to
celebrate getting out of life in prison
with a permanent tattoo on your face but
uh that makes a lot of sense doesn't it
no but in terms of safety though i do
have to point out the high crime rate
here in new york right because my family
is very concerned about me with the
brooklyn shooting yeah i haven't been on
the subway in two and a half years as an
asian woman i feel kind of scared
getting on the new york subway i would
too and i'm not an asian woman
today anyway
who knows what i'll be up to this
weekend
whatever you want joe devito whatever
you want nice little combination with
the black shirt and the blue jacket
thank you thank you where's your
pipe don't know what i'm saying wow um
where does this go i mean like we know
this we see this and it's like it's
still happening
why doesn't where are the adults
i don't i don't know
gascon's done an amazing job here look
at the support he has he's got both the
crips and the bloods
complimenting the unifier bipartisanship
yes
if they could do it so can the
republicans and the democrats yes he's
reached across the aisle yes for these
people it's it's amazing to me that
these people in power seem to have such
hatred for the people they represent
that they're watching the crime go up
and that he's even got a fanboy who's
getting a tattoo of
his name and that is just
that's absurd you know we should get he
should get a qr code tattooed so that
when he's committing his next crime you
just take a picture with your phone and
it goes directly to the police report
yes exactly i love qr codes is that fun
save some time because they're not
they're not concerned with keeping
people like this in prison yeah i'm just
talking about i love them
i just hate uh when you get like a
plastic menu with previous food on it
it drives me crazy you sit down you got
the big giant cheesecake factory menu
they got so many options and yet it all
this stuff starts sliding down into your
lap and it's like i don't need that i
like the qr code there's no food stuck
to the qr code cat
do you ever notice that
i guess i haven't thought about it as
much as you that's why you know that's
why i'm here asking the questions and
you're answering them yep you're
answering are you going to ask me a
question um i'm looking for a good one
okay i had a question for you and then
i've changed my mind because i'm a
little bit worried about gene trapped in
an elevator yeah you know it looks like
it's kind of like throwing me off a
little bit off my game but it's throwing
him off too no you i can almost hear him
his fate screams and you know there's
not a lot of air in that elevator and
he's a big boy
let's talk about tattoos you've dated
men with neck tattoos of course several
yes
but that's because it's hot
[Laughter]
all right what tell them
they'll be a guy he's not that
attractive then he's got a neck tattoo
and you're like all right there you go
all right but i don't have to be on the
neck or can it be anywhere it's hotter
on the i mean preferably it's all over
the place but
what do you make of this
let's stick to the topic you've gone off
topic it's very i took us there yes you
took us there you're like a drunk mom on
a field trip
not yet someday maybe yes uh i think
that you know in general i think a lot
of sentencing enhancements and mandatory
minimums can lead to a lot of injustice
i don't like the way
that they kind of remove the ability to
consider things on a case-by-case basis
i don't think that the place we should
be starting is getting murderers out
early
yeah i think that there's a lot of
things we can improve in terms of our
criminal justice system
i'm not
i'm not losing sleep over murderers i
might lose sleep with more murderers
around yes well what you're talking
about the problem here is recidivism
right we used to lock people up who
repeatedly did things now we let them
out and they recidivize i think that's a
verb he didn't do things he did a murder
he did a murder that's the one i really
don't like no and then they just keep
doing it over and over again isn't
gascon being recalled
i think he is there's a recall i believe
petitioned against him and there's a
recall election against his clone up in
san francisco a few weeks from now yes
yes a lot of people will be watching
that one very closely the thing is and i
think cat's point is really important
like on a more serious note policy-wise
i think we can talk about criminal
justice reform for non-violent offenders
right and this is what this is how they
sell it typically to us but this is the
most violent offender this is a murderer
and a gang member who used a gun they
say they're all against guns and then
they're figuring out ways to get him out
of prison earlier that is the opposite
of good public policy and it's going to
swing the pendulum back hardcore to like
a law and order message and i think
that's part of the reason republicans
are going to
sweep up
it's a good point for people who talk
about gun control but it is it's a bait
and switch then murder it's like we just
want the not the peaceful people out but
all the people that are being let out
there's a lot of violent ones there's
gonna be 70 000 more that are being
released i guess over this year in
california alone a number i just made up
no i didn't i either that or i dreamt it
but there is 70 000 i remember it all
right before we go another reminder this
is so exciting we're less than two weeks
away from welcoming back our studio
audience it's gonna be a big one
starting may 2nd we got a new studio to
get your free tickets go to foxnews.com
gutfeld up next does disney need a plan
for a more inclusive peter pan
maybe
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis you will not
get it anywhere else